chasing through a subway tunnel back up
through a storm drain adrian and i got
engaged and then we busted him with half
a kilo of coke in his sock
what did you just say
so we can wrap it in silk or form our
rustic feel burlap oh that's neat but we
want these nubs to be toyed excuse me
could we wrap the flowers in new york
times crossword puzzles from key dates
in our lives oh is that something you'd
like
here's the deposit i designed you a
signature cocktail i call it the
peraltiago
and the judges give it a score of
jeremy did you make that cake that i
called you about yes i wasn't entirely
sure if you were joking or not but
the nakatomi plaza cake the groom is on
a licorice house welcome to the wedding
pal oh amy
these nups may be getting too tight
wedding's starting soon how are things
going i was just ordained at
www.internetministrynumeral4cheap.com
but i'm having some trouble with my
speech all we got so far is a poem oh a
poem sounds romantic
marriage is a contract between two
adults of different families
it's a haiku
and a fact
it works on two levels oh it feels a
little impersonal what did the officials
say when you got married not much
when gay marriage was legalized we
weren't sure if or when it was gonna be
struck down so speed was of the essence
and do you kevin yes
and do you yes yes we do
we're married
i remarked afterwards that i wish the
officiant had been more efficient
it was very funny kevin still talks
about it
maybe i should open with that zinger
it is amazingly funny
i'm just not sure this is the right
crowd for it
no zinger
no haiku then i have nothing
maybe i should wing it
love
it sustains you
it's like
oatmeal okay
okay
not bad for winging it i lied
it took me two hours to write that i
have an announcement to make when i was
in that uzbek prison choking on my own
blood because my face was being beaten
in i realized
life is funny that's what you realized
and it's short we're picking up where we
left off when adrian went into hiding
we're getting married tomorrow oh
tomorrow that's real quick thank you
sarge
and we want it to be beautiful and lush
and romantic just like a nancy meyers
movie she's our favorite director oh i
love you've got mail that's nora ephron
you idiot i know
whoa
you really made the balloon arch maid no
i birthed her
there's no form more graceful than the
orange no object more whimsical than the
balloon yes you and i think that but
polo rosa think
good point rosa would want a much much
bigger balloon arch
while pimento stares at rosa we'll all
be staring at
her
yes we will she's truly breathtaking
there's a double meaning to that the
breath that it takes to inflate all
those balloons of course i use the hand
pump but the bone mold still works
oh no what's happening someone tell me
what's happening i got some more bad
news huh oh wow
that thing's huge then rosa want things
to be classy i mean she's getting
married not finishing a marathon joe
says the hair guy stay in your lane
bucko right santiago the arch sucks i'm
sorry i didn't want to say anything
because you're my boss and you were so
excited but the truth is every time i
look at it i want to die and take you
with me
well i wish you said something before i
spent all day making it of course you
didn't want to
burst my bubble
pun intended and then
you did
yeah um i just wanted to thank you for
all your help yesterday i didn't do much
there was nothing
good day
what's going on just very busy
get back to work wait what do you have
in there
a balloon arch oh my god captain
she is magnificent
vindication
[Music]
i'm captain raymond holt welcome
marriage is a contract
but it's not much more than that
marriage is love it's
commitment
it's joy
it's understanding it's patience it's
anger
it's reconciliation
it's everything it's like oatmeal
it
sustains you
darlene do you take lynn to be your
lawfully wedded husband i do lin do you
take darlene to be your lawfully wedded
wife i do i now pronounce you husband
and wife you may kiss the bride
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i gotta hand it to you captain that was
some ceremony it wasn't difficult i
simply said what i wish had been said
when kevin and i got married oh well
then i never would have heard your
hilarious efficient officiant quip
you're right i regret nothing
but all this does make me think i might
enjoy a more
festive expression of our commitment to
one another are you suggesting we hold
an honest-to-goodness wedding oh nothing
too elaborate we're not the kardashian
west's after all
they are a musician and a celebrity
personality who recently wedded yes yes
i know they were answers on jeopardy i
think you mean questions
you guys are fun
[Music]
please be seated
friends
colleagues
gawking new yorkers
we are here today to celebrate the
marriage of jake peralta and amy
santiago
i've known you both for the last five
years and it has been a true pleasure to
watch your distracting childish rivalry
evolve into a distracting childish
courtship and now into what i'm sure
will be a distracting child is marriage
i'm proud of you
and i love you both
permission to say it back permission
grounded love you sir love you captain
now i believe you prepared your own vows
yes i
was going to do an adam's family-themed
wrap but my beatboxer isn't here that's
the only reason it's not happening so
ames
today has been a crazy day
but
i shouldn't be surprised
because we've had a lot of crazy days
there was our first date
our first kiss
the first time you told me you loved me
and the day you told me you would marry
me
also yesterday
and the day before that and the day
before that
because
every single day that i get to be with
someone as amazing as you is crazy to me
i love you
and i'm worried about dancing in front
of our friends
the end
okay well
i've been planning this wedding for the
last six months and if you told me
yesterday everything that was gonna go
wrong
i would have had a panic attack that
sent me into the er
but i'm here
and i've never been happier
life is unpredictable
not everything's in our control but as
long as you're with the right people you
can handle anything
and you jake peralta
are the right person for me
but i do have some bad news
there is a bomb at this wedding as well
what your butt
your butt is the bomb there will be no
survivors
i love you so much you're my dream girl
i love you too
i can't wait to spend the rest of my
life with you
ring bearer please bring the rings but i
thought cheddar was sick oh my god
you got the robot there's a robot at my
wedding yeah i felt bad about how
everything went down today so i offered
to help oh that's nice also are you guys
doing the thing where someone gets to
object to this union or is that later
we're not doing that you've outsmarted
me congratulations okay moving on
do you amy santiago take jake peralta to
be your husband
i do
and do you jake peralta take amy
santiago to be your wife
i absolutely do
[Music]
by the power vested in me by the state
of new york i'd like to announce that
your honeymoon vacation request status
has officially been moved from pending
to approved
you're married you may kiss the bride
[Applause]
you